-Our next guests are brother
and talented actors.
You know one from films
like "Ex Machina"
and the "Star Wars"
and "Harry Potter" franchises,
the other from "Peaky Blinders
and "Phantom Thread."
Their show, "Frank of Ireland,
premieres April 16th
on Amazon Prime video.
Let's take a look.
-Doofus, this is your room
-I know.
We be roomies.
-[ Sighs ]
No, silly.
That's where my brother sleeps
You're in with me, buster.
How's that?
-I don't know, Doofus.
What if I'm with a lady?
-I don't mind watching.
-Please welcome to the sho
Domhnall and Brian Gleeson
How are you, gentlemen?
-Pretty good.
How are you doing, Seth?
-I'm doing very well.
It's so nice to see you both
Doofus is the name
of one of the characters here.
And, Domhnall,
you play a Doofus.
And I'm wondering,
when two brothers create a sho
and one brother -- I should sa
one character's named Doofus
how do you decide
who's gonna play the Doofus?
-It's basically
an I.Q. test, essentially.
It's a very strictly...
[ Laughter ]
...formulated plan
where we do an I.Q. test each.
I came out on bottom,
and I got Doofus,
and I'm very,
very happy with it.
-Well, it works out very well.
It should be noted that, Brian
you basically play a man-child
It's not like
the other character
is a genius or anything.
-No, no.
I decided to take an eye tes
'cause I didn't read --
read properly.
No, and, yeah, we had to wrestle
at the end to sort it out.
-You obviously --
you're brothers.
You are both actors.
But do you approach
the way you perform differently?
Have you found that
working together?
-I'd say we're probably quit
different, aren't we, Brian?
Yeah, I've always, kind of
admired the way that Brian works
and the way he's been kind o
able to access characters.
So, you know, I tried to kind of
pick up some tips along the way.
There was one scene where we -
His character in the show
has lost his mother.
He's drugged her up at home,
kind of trying
to be responsible,
so she'll stay in bed whil
he goes and does the shopping.
And when he gets back,
she's gone.
He doesn't know where she is
and he's really worried
about her.
And we were supposed to be
running in somewhere
to find where she --
you know, where she'd gone to,
and he's worried,
you know, whatever has happened.
And I looked over,
and Brian was warming up,
and I was like, "What the --
What's he doing?"
He was muttering something
to himself
to get himself in character.
I was like, "This is amazing."
And I listened,
and he was saying,
"That time I lost Dipper
on the beach.
That time I lost Dipper
on the beach."
He was remembering a time
he lost our dog."
Which, I mean, blew my mind.
You know, that's deeper than
I think I've ever --
even than I've ever gone.
[ Laughter ]
-Brian, is this a --
This is obviously a very
traumatic memory of yours.
-It's Stanislavski.
I'm a student of Stanislavski.
You know, sense memory,
emotional recall.
But I did lose the dog
when I took him out for a walk
on the beach.
And in a very Frank Marth
sort of way,
I didn't really look for him
I just kind of shouted
at the sky
and just had a meltdown,
and then I went home
to confess to mom and dad.
And I really had to tune mysel
up 'cause I got to confess
And I went into the kitchen,
and mom was there, and I said,
"Mom, I have a confession.
She said, "What is it?"
I said,
"I've lost Dipper, the dog."
And she said, "No, you didn't.
He's right there
under the kitchen table."
[ Laughter ]
So he had at some point
in that walk, he said,
"You know what?
I don't like this anymore.
I'm heading home."
[ Laughter ]
-My worry is that you never --
that you left
with an empty lead.
My worry is you left that hous
with a lead
trailing along the ground
and Dipper was never with you.
-Oh, the dog never even
left the house.
-Yeah.
He was there the whole time.
-It would explain
the shouting at the sky anyway
-[ Laughing ]
-I feel like you might have also
made a very good Doofus,
all things being equal.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, Seth.
And you, too.
[ Laughter ]
-You -- You mentioned --
-We saw you
trying to pronounce our names.
We saw you trying
to pronounce our names
before the show started.
-Yeah.
-How dare you call me a Doofus
You went through
Domhnall four times.
You hadn't changed the nam
on the card.
They'll edit all this out.
And then by the end of it,
you finally got it right..
-No, I'm gonna leave it in
-...and then you tripped up --
then you tripped up on "Breean,"
'cause it looks like "Brian.
We all saw it, Seth.
-You know what?
I'm gonna leave it in.
And my next question
is about your brother, Fergus,
who I love, because you say it
the way it's spelled.
[ Laughter ]
-It's pronounced "Feyuk,"
you idiot.
[ Laughter ]
-No -- I know.
You know what?
We don't have time for Fergus.
But, no -- But, actually,
your brother Fergus,
he's a singer.
He provided a song for the show.
-Yes, yes, he did.
[ Laughter ]
He sang a song that our
co-writer Michael Moloney wrote.
-Is he --
Was he a "yes" right away
when you asked him
to sing the song?
-Yeah, I think so.
Domhnall, no?
-No. No.
[ Laughter ]
He wanted --
He wanted a little bit of this
-Sure, sure.
-He's in it for the money.
-You got your dad,
the wonderful actor,
Brendan Gleeson,
he appeared in the show.
Did he also want the money
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah.
You've got to pay them.
You want the right people,
you got to pay them.
-Do you get nervous
when he shows up on set,
as either an actor or a so
or neither or both?
-No, I think he has
so much enthusiasm
and so much love for the craft
which is what I always
loved about him.
And we were on set when he cam
on his first day,
and he had a suitcase
full of his own clothes,
but also costume clothes.
Sometimes it's hard to tell th
difference between the two
[ Laughter ]
But he came in with
lots of ideas,
and he tried them out for us
as we were having lunch.
You know,
he went into the trailer,
come out with a new costume,
went into his trailer,
come out in a new costume.
We very slowly
found a way where he was happy
But that kind of enthusias
is amazing to be around.
-It was so --
It was so weird.
It was like the weirdest
"Pretty Woman" montage
of him trying on -- like,
coming out of his trailer to us.
Well, you don't know
whether to eat.
When your father is changing
into sexy leather jackets
in front of you,
is it weirder to continue eating
or to stop eating?
It's a real question, Seth -
which is weirder?
-You try to take your bite
as he goes.
When his back turns,
you try to sneak a bite in
You don't --
You certainly don't act --
you don't eat
when he's looking at you.
-I never spit the food out
either.
That's the worst thing
you can do.
-I actually guzzled hungrily
while he did his pirouette
I messed it all up.
-That's the worst.
-Of course -- a hungry guzzle,
of course, is fine.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Gentlemen, thank you
so much for being here.
Congratulations on the show.
It's lovely to see you both.
-Lovely to see you too, Seth
Thank you.
-Thanks.
-"Frank of Ireland"
premieres April 16th
on Amazon Prime Video.